c'est l'une des positions de l'armée
ukrainienne au nord de kharkiv dans le
champ juste derrière un char russe
détruits et encore fumant
nous sommes à seulement dix kilomètres
du centre de la deuxième ville du pays
ses positions les ukrainiens les
tiennent pour l'instant mais les combats
sont intenses selon le commandant avec
qui nous avons pu parler les accalmies
d'ailleurs son côté
un coup de feu retentit
les hommes se positionne
nous quittons les lieux
lorsque nous revenons dans le
centre-ville plusieurs détonations
et des civils en panique courir dont les
rues de kharkiv est devenu le quotidien
plus tôt ce matin un missile non
explosées s'est plantée au beau milieu
de ce passage piéton
bien sûr depuis les démineurs longs
extraits mais voici à quoi ressemblait
cette scène en plein centre-ville
les habitants n'en reviennent toujours
pas
vous voyez ce trou là
c'est elle a fiché dans le sol sa mesure
est de mettre à peu près un missile
dans ce quartier résidentiel en revanche
un autre missile a bel et bien exploser
les habitants cet après-midi dégage pour
les vitres brisées
pas de morts
quelques blessés légers les adultes et
les enfants dormaient au moment de la
frappe
ma fille dormait ici dans ce qui
est heureusement le rideau qui était
tirée la protéger des débris de verre on
a eu beaucoup de chance
une enfant de 8 ans qui veut nous
montrer sur le portable de son père
les débris du projectile
en ukraine les fillettes savent
désormais à quoi ressemble la guerre
on a dû dormir dans le métro il y avait
beaucoup de monde mon propre pays les
gens étaient assis sur les escaliers
notamment nous on est restés au même
endroit parce qu'il y avait un petit
chien très mignon pas je l'aimé bien
comme hier le métro est le refuge un
casque de vélo sur la tête pour cette
famille tout est bon pour tenter de se
protéger
les choeurs sont serrés
sais-tu craignent un travail dans un
hôtel en france à metz il est venu pour
aider sa mère elle vit ici on va essayer
de quitter le pays parce que dans toutes
les villes c'est dangereux ils attaquent
tout les toutes les villes les bases
militaires les un record on sait pas
trop quoi faire on sait même pas comment
comment partir plus loin le sous sol
d'un hôtel
personnel et clients attendent la
prochaine accalmie pour remonter des
civils qui ont passé l'état de
sidération du premier jour et qui semble
s'installer dans un incroyable quotidien
où les chars russes peuvent surgir à
tout moment